Humans are having a major impact on the
earth's climate and not much of it is
good for us.
Disappear species go extinct and we've
already raised the Earth's temperature by
about one degree Celsius. That might
not seem like a lot, but it is.
It's a huge jump in just the past 250
years and scientists and world leaders
have agreed that two degrees Celsius
is the upper limit before four things
become more intense.
Yet we're predicted to reach four degrees
Celsius by the year 2100 faced with
this information,
many of us show concern
yet find frustration with
government were slow to act
and corporations who
are even slower to act.
So here are 10 ways that you
can take action. Number one,
reduce electricity when you're not using
something such as lights or computer,
your television, etc. Turn it off.
Furthermore, if not inconvenient,
unplug it as low.
Your lights may be off.
They may still use energy if
they're plugged in this method,
like many other methods,
we will mention in this video we'll also
help you save money. Number two, recycle.
This is an obvious but overlooks method.
We're using plastic, paper, cardboard,
glass, metal, et Cetera.
We'll save huge amounts in the energy
that was expended in harvesting these
resources, which if not
recycled, may simply go to waste.
If you don't have neighborhood recycling
final recycling center near you,
this will reduce landfill pollution,
deforestation,
and many other harmful things to
our environment. Number three,
buy local food or grow your own.
Not only this,
transporting food critic
significant amount of pollution,
but industrial agriculture also
release this as a significant amount of
greenhouse gas and pesticides
harmful to the environment.
Buying local food or having a garden is
a healthy choice for both you and the
environment. Number four,
use reusable water bottles.
Instead of buying water bottles,
you use a reusable wants
to cut down on plastic use.
Most bottled water is not that
much healthier than tap water,
but if you're still concerned,
I would recommend buying a water filter
and just try to make sure that this
water bottle is BPA free as BPA has
been linked to cancer. Number Five,
change your transportation habits.
Millions of people traveling from place
to place each day as responsible for a
huge amounts of greenhouse gas emission.
Considered driving instead of flying.
Consider taking public
transportation instead of driving.
Consider walking or riding a bike as your
best way to not produce greenhouse gas
and stay in shape. Number six,
consider using a clothes line.
It may seem old fashioned,
but your washer and dryer are some of
the biggest consumers of energy in your
house.
Cuts down on this energy use by letting
your clothes dry out in the sun.
Number seven, keep warm with
clothing or blankets in the winter.
Consider turning your thermostat down
and cooler temperatures and instead
wearing warmer clothing each
degree above 70 degrees Fahrenheit,
maybe responsible for around
7% of extra energy output.
Number eight's grow plants. Plants not
only turned carbon dioxide into oxygen,
but much of the plant itself is made
out of carbon taken from the air.
Having indoor or outdoor plants,
letting your yard go out a little bit or
finding a space to plant a tree are all
excellent ways of helping.
Number nine, reduce water usage.
Wasted water is especially bad for the
environment in many parts of the world.
Can't afford to wastewater.
Turn off water when you're not using it
and try to use as little as possible by
turning off on use faucets,
reducing shower times of five to 10
minutes and running dishwashers or washing
machines. Only one completely
full. Number 10 get involved.
Finding local organizations dedicated to
protecting the environment by reducing
greenhouse gas emissions.
Protecting forests and endangered species
and more is a great way to increase
your positive environmental influence.
Contacting politicians,
protesting and raising awareness
are all effective ways of change.
By implementing these methods,
we can make a difference.
As real change starts with the
individual person taking action together,
we can save our planet for more
videos on a wide range of subjects.
I would invite you to check out the rest
of fire of learning at subscribed to
see more of these videos in the future.
Thank you for watching.